evening everyone welcome to the next
revolution I'm Steve Hilton and this is
the home of positive populism pro-worker
pro-family Pro community and especially
pro America important show tonight
coronavirus the economy and the
blue-collar boom 2020 latest that
outrageous Chuck Schumer business last
week we also have an unbelievable loony
left for you and of course a new Joe
Biden comedy segment with me live in Los
Angeles for the hour Adam Carolla and
Tammy Bruce Jenner Ellis and Taryn
Figaro they'll be joining us tonight as
well
all right there they are and here we go
we'll get to coronavirus in a second but
let's start positive we saw an
incredible jobs report on Friday two
hundred and seventy three thousand new
jobs in February almost a hundred
thousand more than expected
another 85,000 on top of that with
revisions to the previous two months
totals it's not just a number it's over
a third of a million Americans working
who weren't before just in the last few
weeks unemployment at a 50-year low
earnings continued to grow now if we
want this success to continue we have to
understand why it's happening the policy
foundations the Trump haters say it's
all thanks to Obama Barack Obama
literally saved the economy and the
benefits that we're seeing now from
Trump they are though they're the ripple
effects there is a narrative here that I
think is borne by the facts that suggest
that even if the overall numbers are
good they're not that much better or
substantially different from those under
Obama frankly these are Obama era policy
that allowed Trump to have two years it
was a gift it really was that is
dangerously wrong it means people will
think we can safely go back to Obama era
policies without hurting working
Americans that Trump just inherited a
good economy story is a lie and tonight
we'll show you the hard evidence it's
true that if you look at average
economic growth you see roughly the same
performance with Obama and Trump but
averages missed the life cycle of an
economic expansion it's much harder to
create growth in jobs at the end and the
beginning here's the pattern you
typically see growth is negative during
a recession it quickly accelerates to a
peak as the economy bounces back before
falling more gradually until then
next recession hits if the expansion
that followed the Great Recession the
Obama economy had lasted the same length
as the previous one we would have gone
into recession last June but we didn't
our economy kept growing so why did the
Trump economy not follow the pattern of
previous expansions perhaps because the
world economy was picking up speed
actually the rest of the world has been
slowing down Germany's GDP growth is
naught point five percent Japan's
naught point nine percent the
explanation and the policy lesson it's
so vital to learn is the change that
happened right there yes the 2016
election with the exception of one
quarter growth hasn't fallen below that
level since for three reasons
one a pro enterprise pro-business
approach that boosted business
confidence which translates into more
capital investment to deregulation
especially on energy which unleashed
American innovation and made America a
net exporter of oil for the first time
in 75 years three tax cuts for workers
but also employers so they can afford to
expand and invest creating more jobs and
higher productivity which enables higher
wages the trumpet haters say these
policies just help the rich that again
is a total lie the Trump boom is not a
one-percent boom is a blue-collar boom
look at earnings the haters say Trump is
just continuing the wage growth started
under Obama again you might believe this
if you look at the averages they say the
same on jobs and yes if you look at the
totals each month during both
administrations it seems like a
continuation but look behind the
averages here's how the top 25% and
bottom 25% did under Obama for much of
his time wage growth for the richest was
higher than wage growth for the poorest
by a wide margin now look at the picture
with Trump wage growth for the poorest
has been higher than for the richest
every month he's been in office and for
the first time in almost 10 years wage
growth for less skilled workers matched
wage growth for high-skilled workers
under Obama the rich got richer and the
poorest were stuck with Trump sure the
rich did well but the poorest and the
middle class are doing even better
look at household income in many ways
the most important measure in three
years with Trump household incomes have
gone up five times more than under eight
years of Obama and on jobs we're doing
far better than what you'd expect at
this stage of an expansion if you look
at the previous two expansions the
average monthly job gained during the
last year was 120,000 but over the last
year with Trump the average monthly gain
is 200 and 1,000 the monthly Trump job
gains are over 65 percent higher than
normal but it's also about the types of
jobs added the elitists laughed at Trump
when he said he'd bring back
manufacturing he just says well I'm no
I'm gonna negotiate a better deal well
hot what how exactly are you going to
negotiate that what magic wand do you
have what magic wand you have in 2018
more manufacturing jobs were added that
at any time for 30 years and we can
expect even more thanks to the new u.s.
MCA the most Pro worker trade deal in
history the point of all this is not to
praise any one politician but to explain
to all of them especially any
Republicans tempted to go back to
establishment economics after Trump
exactly what the policy mix is that most
helps those who are left behind by
globalization and open borders and here
we come to the central policy innovation
of the past three years pro-business on
tax and regulation pro-worker on trade
and immigration and in the end this is
delivered not just economic success but
something that strengthens our society
too that helps repair our torn social
fabric in the fourth quarter of last
year over 74 percent of people entering
the labor force came off the sidelines
the highest percentage since records
began that's the power of Trump's
blue-collar boom it lifts up the
Forgotten men and women left on the
scrap heap by the elitist policies of
the past all of this is put at risk by
Bernie or Biden just take one of the
central planks of the blue-collar boom
lower business taxes right now pretty
much whatever international measure you
pick it's the lowest here in America now
look where Biden wants to put it it
would lit
be the highest that is a disaster for
investment for jobs for household
incomes Bernie wants to take it to 35%
of course they both want to massively
raise taxes increased regulations closed
down domestic energy build up the
bureaucracy centralized power on and on
it goes
anti-worker anti-family anti-community
whether it's socialism with bernie or
the swamp with Biden it is a disaster
for America